Well,
welcome back.
And what I want to do this morning is to
be cognizant of the fact that you have,
as you all know,
the hour exam later this
week in a different format.
And I've written to you about
that. Uh, because of that,
what I thought would be useful to do this
morning would be to have something of
a review session I in which
we make explicit some of the,
uh,
ways in which it's useful to think about
epidemic diseases and in which we go
over some of the terrain that we've
covered thus far in the semester.
But at the same time,
I want to talk about introduce
a new and important disease,
which is syphilis and provide a bit
of background for the book that you're
reading this week, which is
Alan grants. No magic bullet.
And you'll be wanting to know,
well, where did syphilis come from?
What's the historical background?
So I'm going to try to introduce that
while going over some of the issues that
we've already presented.
So you'll find a lump that's already
familiar this morning as we go back in
time,
uh,
covering major issues that we've dealt
with and I hope at the same time to be
introducing something
new which has syphilis.
So we'll look at the oil period we've
covered in the course through the lens of
syphilis. So that's the
direction in which we're headed.
Now in order to talk about a variety
of epidemic diseases and their impact,
we want to have,
uh,
some comparative questions
that we make explicit.
That is what is it that we need to know
about each of the diseases that we're
talking about?
What are the crucial aspects that
make it a transformative force or not?
What are the historical variables?
I have a sort of suggestion of maybe
10 major questions that we ought to be
thinking about with regard to each of
the diseases that we examine throughout
the semester. Uh, first
one is these questions,
by the way,
are not canonical.
I don't mean that you shouldn't be asking
other questions as well and indeed I
hope you will,
but I think we should know at least the
answers to these 10 questions and then
build on not as a foundation.
A first major question for any of the
diseases we're talking about was what's
the total mortality and morbidity that's
caused by the epidemic and question the
mortality, the total numbers
of deaths, morbidity,
the total number of cases.
That's an important factor that needs
to be kept in taken into account and
assessing the impact of the epidemic.
A second question has to do with the term
we introduced long ago a phrase which
was the case fatality rate
and the related question with that is,
is there an effective therapy or means
of prevention or instead business society
experience the disease and feeling itself
to be helpless and physicians feeling
the same.
The case fatality rate is,
we could call it the
kill rate of a disease.
The percentage of cases
that terminate and death.
And we know that for example,
in dealing with plague,
one of the features of it and Asiatic
collar as well was a very high case
fatality rate of plague,
50 to 80% cholera,
something like 50%.
At the other extreme when we come to it,
we'll see that influenza has a very high
morbidity but quite a low case fatality
rate.
And that's related I think to the impact
that that disease influenza has on
society which isn't
associated with such um,
uh, terror as say, plague or cholera.
That's an important variable down
is the kill rate of the disease.
Another factor,
a third question we need to ask is
what's the nature of the symptoms of the
Infectious Disease in question?
Are they particularly painful?
Are they degrading according
to the norms of the time?
And we've seen for example,
in dealing with plague and cholera that
a major feature about them was not,
their symptoms were
agonizing and dehumanizing.
Clearly as we turn to syphilis,
um,
it's symptoms also,
uh,
were extremely important in the way
that the disease was experienced.
Tuberculosis on the other hand,
and we'll be looking at that was seen
at the time to make it suffers more
intelligent,
more romantic,
more beautiful in some sense,
at least in the first half of
the 19th century. So that, uh,
what is the nature of the symptoms
is a crucially important question.
Another fourth question that I hope
you'll bear in mind throughout the course
and in your review for the
exercise this week is the question,
is this disease new
or is it familiar to the population?
Familiar diseases tend
not to be so terrifying.
The population is also likely to have
some degree of immunity to the disease,
and the disease is likely,
or my have already mutated
to become less deadly.
Examples are the so called diseases
of childhood like chicken pox,
mumps and measles,
normally relatively mild,
but in populations to which they're newly
introduced, they can be devastating.
A fifth question has to do with the,
what's the profile of the
victims of the disease?
Is this a disease that's an affliction
of the young and the elderly
that is experienced as a more normal
course of a disease in accord with
society's expectations and past experience
or does it instead striked down,
particularly those who are in the
prime of life thereby no longer seeming
natural but as something extraordinary
and the experience of the population.
And it also means that the disease
is likely to maximize its um,
fine.
It's economic and financial impact
to be particularly destabilizing to a
community.
Cholera in this regard for example,
was terrifying because of the way in
which it seemed to afflict the those who
were the bulwarks of
families and of communities.
A six question, that's important. Uh,
what's the class profile of the sufferers?
How,
what sorts of people in society
are stricken with the affliction?
Is this a disease of poverty such as
cholera is usually thought of or is it an
affliction that strikes everyone without
particular reference to class or social
and economic status like influenza or um,
syphilis?
Indeed a seventh important question is
what is the mode of transmission of the
disease?
Is it transmitted person to person?
Is it transmitted by contaminated
food and water are involved?
Is it spread through the air by droplets?
Is it spread by sexual contact?
And clearly I think will be arguing
that the mode of transmission is really
crucial and in sexually
transmitted diseases.
I think that that is going fairly self
evident and a very important factor in
the social impact of those diseases.
And eighth important question is whether
the disease is full minute and it's
course or is it slow acting
and a wasting disease.
If we look, for example, at cholera,
one of the features and
in a striking one is not,
it was a one of the most
full minute of diseases.
It would strike down the sufferer and
will you could board a train and die
before you reached your destination as
the disease ran its course that quickly
through the human body or on the other
hand is the disease one that takes years,
perhaps even decades to run its course.
Um,
and an example of that of course would
be tuberculosis or HIV AIDS in our own
time.
And ninth important question we need
always to bear in mind is how was the
disease understood by the
population that it's infecting?
Is it a Pacino as a punishment of God?
Is it later on thought to be something
that comes from the dangerous classes or
later on is understood to
be a microbial infection?
And those ways in which the disease or
understood is understood have enormous
impact on how the population
reacts to the disease.
A 10th and a variable is what's
the duration of the epidemic.
Influenza,
for example,
passes through a locality
in a matter of weeks.
Normally cholera or plague tend to
have epidemics that last for months and
tuberculosis,
one might describe as an
epidemic in slow motion that,
uh,
afflicts a community for
a whole century or more.
So those are 10 major questions that
I hope that you'll be bearing in mind
throughout the course.
I think they'll help you in dealing
with the diseases in a comparative and
finding out and teasing out why some
diseases have an impact of one kind and
others are very different.
Well this morning I'd like to go through
some of this material again in a review
manner by looking at syphilis.
Uh,
why syphilis at this stage of the course,
I think that it provides background for
no magic bullet and it also helps us to
look at some of the material that we've
already covered and that you'll be
writing about in the next few days.
Well first let's deal then
with the chronology and this
helps us to step back in
time from the 19th century
to go back indeed to uh,
the plague years.
Syphilis in fact was contemporary
and its onset with plug
and like plague it the time it was a
new disease that first struck Europe in
this case in the late 1490s.
And we'll see that there's an important
Darwinian evolution that takes place,
which is to say that the syphilis of
the 15th and 16th centuries is quite
different from syphilis thereafter.
Syphilis and its first century or so
was what we might call the great pox a
disease that was much more
severe than modern syphilis.
So syphilis clearly begins as a
dreadful epidemic that swept Europe.
And then the world after the 16th century,
it's still a very serious illness,
but it's much milder,
less fatal unless agonizing.
So today is the,
we're going to deal primarily
with the early syphilis,
the syphilis of the great pops.
Now the mode of transmission,
it's clearly important and
we need to examine, uh,
what are the particular features of Stds
of sexually transmitted diseases among
the venereal diseases
to use an older term,
syphilis was king from the 15th Century
until the late 21st 20th when there was
the appearance of a much
more threatening competitor,
Hiv aids
and more in more recent times after
World War Two and the introduction of the
era of antibiotics,
particularly penicillin and sex education,
there's been a radical decline
in the incidents of syphilis.
And for a time there were even heady
hopes that it could be eradicated all
together, but more, most recently,
unfortunately it's made
something of a comeback.
Now keep in mind too,
that historically the STDs
weren't carefully distinguish
one from another until
late in the 19th century.
Other significant STDs,
gonorrhea and Shanker in particular
weren't known to be separate diseases.
There were thought to be simply
milder manifestations of syphilis.
So there was,
we might say a unicity theory
of the venereal diseases.
There was thought to be one disease,
no,
uh,
reason for dealing with syphilis.
Now at this point in the course is that
it had a significant impact on medical
science in ways that we've
already touched upon. Uh,
with regard to bubonic plague.
That is to say like plague syphilis
seemed clearly to be contagious
and it was understood from the
beginning to be spread somehow.
No one quite knew how
through sexual contact.
And so like plague syphilis challenged
the reigning orthodoxy of humor realism
and gave rise through someone
we've already met. And we'll,
we can look at it again in a
moment, uh, through Geraldo Muff,
Rocco Storto and particular
to the doctrine of contagion.
And it generated also the idea that
disease might be a specific entity.
Syphilis was clearly something distinctive
and many people regarded it as a
disease on its own rather than us.
Any example of humoral imbalance.
So syphilis had an impact on medical
science and influenced as along with plug
the, uh, if we like the,
I began to make humeral doctrine
less stable at its foundations.
Well where does syphilis come from?
What are its origins in here?
Or there's a major debate,
uh,
that has not been resolved and
it continues down to this day.
I'll put forward a couple of candidates.
Uh,
and I think it's more important to know
these different origins theories of the
origins of sinfulness because they
have a big impact on how the disease is
experienced rather than expecting us to
resolve the issue of where the disease
came from.
In fact,
let's note how people
thought the disease appeared.
A first theory was the one
associated with Christopher Columbus.
This is the Americanist idea
of the origins of syphilis.
And we've talked already about the,
um,
Colombian exchange.
So I just wanted to review that again.
That's Columbus's first trip.
And this is the idea of the Colombian
exchange of what was transmitted from the
old world to the new, the
old world contributing, uh,
various foodstuffs like coffee,
beans and rice, livestock,
cows and various diseases as
you already know, smallpox,
measles and so on. And the new world, uh,
being the source for Europeans of corn,
potatoes,
um, and so on. Certain
precious metals, tobacco.
And there is the idea that uh,
the Americanists so-called argued that
it was Columbus and his crew who brought
back syphilis from the new world.
This idea held that syphilis was endemic
in the new world spread to Columbus's
sailors and was reported
to Europe on their return.
The problem,
of course for the theory is that there
isn't in fact any definitive evidence
that syphilis did exist in the new world
at the time or the Columbus sale or
Columbus has sailors were actually
infected in the manner required by the
theory.
So the evidence in supportive
this is entirely circumstantial.
The chronology works.
That's one factor.
And another is that there isn't in fact
in the medical literature before this
time a disease like syphilis anywhere
in Europe and more recently Paleo
pathologists haven't unearthed evidence
of syphilis and European cemeteries.
It clearly seems to be a disease
that was a new or blood is used an
anachronistic term,
an emerging disease in the 1490s and
because of Eurocentrism and perhaps
xenophobia, there was a
preference to blame. The other,
a second idea that,
uh,
was very popular was not syphilis.
Instead of being a of American or new
world origins was of Spanish or African
origin.
This theory held the,
perhaps the disease was present in Europe
for a long time but had been confined
to a small corner of the
continent perhaps and one can see,
um,
certain sinister views here,
confined perhaps to Jews or Moore's
in Spain and unnoticed my outsiders.
Then with the expulsion
of the Jews and the 1490s,
the disease was
disseminated across Europe.
No.
Among those who propounded this view,
there was clearly a current of racism,
Anti Semitism and xenophobia.
Syphilis was supposed to have
been endemic among the Jews.
Having come perhaps earlier from Africa
and was prevalent in those populations,
uh,
because their sex in some way
was unnatural and out of control.
So syphilis was confined
in Europe to Spain.
This theory argues until the expulsion
of the Jews in 1492 when they unleashed
there contagion on the rest of Europe.
And any case,
what's really clear is that absolutely
no one wanted to acknowledge syphilis as
his or her own four Italian
syphilis was somebody else's.
It was the French disease for the French,
it was the Neapolitan disease.
For Russians it was the Polish disease.
And for every one that was
the great parks or the KLOPP.
Now how do we get the term syphilis?
Where does that come from?
The word itself was coined by the Italian
physician whom you've already met for
our custodial who did something
extraordinary in 1531 which was not,
he wrote a work called syphilis.
Um,
and here was Flocka storto
whose face you've seen again?
No, this work was odd in our
unusual, in a number of respects.
It was a poem written in
Latin and modeled on Virgil.
And as I think about it,
I can't think at the moment of another
poem about an epidemic disease.
It was also an instant success.
It rapidly went through lots of
additions and established for our costs.
Dorros fame even more than
is more scientific works.
It also offered,
what I think we could say was a clearly
moralizing judgmental analysis of this
disease as a scourge of God.
You know the drill by now and in the poem,
the first victim of the disease was a
shepherd who's name was syphilis and the
shepherd had offended the gods by turning
against them and worshiping a king as
a deity.
So in their anger,
the gods afflicted syphilis
with this terrible POCs.
So we can see that built into it from
the beginning was the idea that syphilis
was best understood as the wages of sin.
And there's a further polemical
thrust that's not made explicit,
but as a subtle undertow in the poem.
Remember the poem was written in the 1530s
in the midst of a religious CISM with
Martin Luther,
a devout adherent of orthodoxy.
That is Daca Storto was
and of the Catholic Church.
He was a physician to bishops
archbishops and cardinals and syphilis,
as I've said,
was a shepherd and in Latin,
the word for shepherd
is pastor Pasa stored.
So the men who was punished was a pastor,
not a priest that is
possibly a Protestant leader.
So there's a slight
hint here that syphilis,
the disease as a divine
punishment for the reformation.
So Flocka Storto didn't adhere
to the Americanist position.
Then there's perhaps modern,
a third more modern idea.
Our hypothesis is that
perhaps the causative agent
of syphilis are emerged in a
Darwinian manner. The spiral
[inaudible] or triple noma Apollo,
Adam arose perhaps as a mutation of some
preexisting Trepanier hymns that are
morphologically very similar under
the microscope and perhaps it was,
it emerged as a,
an evolution from the
Trepanier that causes yours.
In any case,
it was clear that whatever
the sight of its origin,
its spread across your with terrifying
rapidity and one can see the role of
warfare in particular in promoting the
movement of syphilis and it's spread
across.
Europe was closely associated
with Charles the eighth of France,
known as Charles the affable,
who lived from 1470 to 98 and
launched a series of wars with Italy,
which he invaded in 1494
at the head of a large,
large army.
The army marched across the Italian
peninsula and reach Naples that Charles
besieged and captured.
He then found himself facing a powerful
coalition of powers that have ultimately
defeated him and after
his forced withdrawal.
The point is that his army disbanded,
and this was a large army,
a mercenary force of tens of thousands
of men from various nationalities,
and a feature of war is that it's
always a providential time for epidemic
disease and sexually transmitted diseases.
In particular,
the army of Charles the
eighth was poorly disciplined.
It indulged and pillage,
plunder and rape,
and it had its numerous camp
followers of beggars and prostitutes.
So among the troops and those
who consorted with them,
the disease flared up and after
they're disbanding and mobilization,
it was disseminated across the continent.
Between 1495 and 1520 something frightful
happened as the epidemic swept Europe
from Naples to Moscow. To Oslo, Madrid,
London,
and every place in between.
So this is the origin of syphilis.
However it arose,
whether it was an imported,
whether it was a newly emerging disease,
uh,
perhaps a mutation from yours,
from a disease already present in Europe,
it was clearly spread by this favorable
opportunity of warfare and the army of
Charles the eighth.
Well,
what's the etiology and
symptomatology of syphilis?
And here,
this is the causative agent,
the Treponema Pallidum or sparky.
This the trip.
And Nema [inaudible] has a special
feature in that it's exquisitely
and fragile and it requires very
precise conditions in order to live.
It cannot survive outside of bodily
fluids and the warmth of the human body.
And therefore it can only be
transmitted by intimate contact.
Indeed,
the spire acute is so delicate that
it can hardly be cultivated in vitro.
And that's one of the reasons that the
development of a vaccine has proved so
difficult.
Well,
there's an initial incubation period
with syphilis and we'll talk about three
stages in,
uh,
it's impact on the individual human body.
The first stage,
and we're talking now about the great pox.
This early stage in the
history of syphilis.
The first stage lasted a month or two
and was marked by a painful and alarming
Shanker at the site of entry of
the spiral keyed into the body.
But this Shanker heals spontaneously just
like lesions in chicken pox or herpes,
but that doesn't mean that the
patient has cured, is cured,
the disease insect persists,
but for a time without
generating symptoms.
Then there's the onset of the second stage
of syphilis between 45 days after the
disappearance of the Shanker and a year.
There are numerous symptoms,
but in the second stage of sinfulness,
only the superficial tissues of the
skin are affected with rash and Boyle's.
Now it was this second stage of syphilis
that was of extraordinary severity.
During the era of the great pox,
it was painful,
disfiguring, incapacitating,
and often fatal.
There were sowers and swellings all over
the body from the soles of the foot to
the crown of the head leaving
disfiguring scabs and pockmarks worse.
The disease was described as
attacking the whole of the body.
It was said to eat it away and consume it.
The body stank and the
surfers were afflicted in an
addition with fever and pain
in their joints.
So intense.
One contemporary wrote that the victims
screamed day and night envying the very
dead.
Let's listen to [inaudible] himself who
described the great parks like this.
He wrote,
remember he was a physician as well
as a poet and the majority of cases,
small ulcers began to
appear on the sexual organs.
They were intractable and
would not depart. Next,
the skin broke out within
crusted postulates.
They soon grew little by little
until they were the size of an Acorn,
which they in fact resembled.
Then these ulcerated puzzles ate away
the skin and sometimes infected not only
the fleshy parts,
but the very bones as well.
In cases where the malady
was firmly established and
the upper parts of the body,
the patients suffered from pernicious
Qatar that eroded the pallet or the
pharynx and tonsils and
some cases the lips,
the nose and eyes were
eaten away or in others,
the whole of the sexual organs.
Moreover,
many patients suffered from the great
deformity or Goomada that developed
besides all of the above symptoms
as if they were not bad enough.
Violent pains,
attack the muscles.
These pains were persistent,
tormented the sufferer chiefly at night.
And we're the most cruel
of all the symptoms.
There is a theory that may be even the
disease was too virulent for its own
good, that his symptoms were
so debilitating as to prevent,
suffers from transmitting it.
And so the modern disease evolved during
the 16th and 17th centuries as a milder
form of the great parks. I'll
show you a couple of, um,
images of extreme forms of modern syphilis
that sad to give us some idea of what
the great pox was like.
Uh,
they're rather of course
unpleasant slides. So I would
tell you that in advance,
but this will give you some idea of
how terrible the great parks was.
Um, it looked like that, or indeed,
uh, like that. So we'll move on.
Uh,
then there's third stage syphilis,
tertiary syphilis,
and in this phase do you have involvement
of the deep tissues and it's symptoms
are things such as what's
called Tabius door solace,
which is a degeneration of the neurons
in the spinal cord and leads therefore to
lack of coordination to a stumbling gate,
um,
and symptoms of that kind to Ataxia,
which means the stumbling gate.
It also leads in this phase
to cardiovascular disease
to often to insanity and
dementia to general
paralysis and to death.
So tertiary syphilis can
be the cause of death.
Well, what we're, if that's
what the disease looked like,
what were some of its effects on society?
Well,
because of its mode of transmission,
syphilis was associated with
terrible social effects with anxiety,
guilt,
pain,
broken relationships,
breakdowns and trust within families,
infertility among women
and like the plague.
And unlike some of the diseases
that we'll be studying,
syphilis was no respecter of
persons of social class or status.
We might,
uh,
perhaps are chronically call it a
democratic disease and that it afflicted
everyone from the bottom
of the social scale.
Touristic crowds learned professionals,
kings,
cardinals, bishops.
Occasionally even popes, um,
such as Julius the second
who was also a syphilitic.
So accordingly,
one might argue syphilis caused
a great strain on society,
but not along the uh,
Fisher's running between
classes as did for example,
Asiatic cholera.
It was also unlike plug and then it was
not terrifyingly swift and it's obvious.
Association with sex meant
that the demeans to avoid it,
we're clear.
And so there was no generalized
terror of the kind that accompanied a,
say,
bluebonnet plague or Asiatic cholera.
Everyone knew how
syphilis could be avoided.
What were the effects on then?
One was a new asceticism.
There was a suspicion of pleasures
and the Protestant world,
an epidemic of syphilis was
perfectly timed not to create.
And here I don't want to be saying that
epidemic diseases created puritanism I'm
would argue instead simply thought
this is a disease that reinforced it.
Asceticism indeed had long been
present in European culture,
but syphilis helped make it more
popular and a widely held sentiment.
And the Catholic world,
one can see a new piety as well in the
Catholic reformation in Janssen aneurysm
for example.
Another impact clearly was in terms
of tensions between the sexes.
Now this is familiar to you.
We're going back over
old ground in our course.
Remember paintings that we saw earlier
of the Garden of Eden and original sin,
Adam drawn into evil bias helpmate eve,
the original [inaudible].
Well,
the passage of syphilis was marked by a
sinister under stone toe of misogyny in
a patriarchal society,
male fears, anxieties,
and indeed guilt.
We're projected onto women who were seen
as the crucial agents and the spread of
this disease.
Two men and two groups of women were
particularly suspect prostitutes first and
here was a prime example of
a new male double standard.
The passage of syphilis was marked by
harsh police measures against prostitutes,
including the closing of brothels and
the rounding up an exile of people from
communities.
There was also a hunt for scape
goats and witch hunts are,
we're part of that.
Another feature was a new religious cult.
The cult in particular of a new saint.
Um,
and this is rather unique,
which is there's only,
as far as I know,
one saint who wasn't a Christian.
And this is job from the book
of job in the Old Testament
Joep ah,
however was actually
said in the book of job.
He had especially a and
especially convincing, um,
defense attorney and that was God himself
because God says in the book of job
that this is the most just of all men.
He's the best and most innocent
and yet to try his faith,
he was scourged by Satan.
And this is the painting
by William Blake of uh,
this scourging of a job by Satan
who's pouring out Boyle's ah,
that will soon torment
him from head to foot.
And the description of the disease that
afflicted job in the book of job is
highly suggestive of what we might
call a venereal disease or STD.
He was covered from head to foot and
boils and yet Jobe was reassuringly free
from sin. We know that because
God told, tells us so. And so,
Joe became the patron
saint of syphilis six.
There was also a public health response
that is to say the building of hospitals
for the incurables who were the syphilis
lytics and there was a new philanthropy
and religious orders that
took over their care.
Let's look for a moment at some of
the treatment regimens that were also
important in this disease.
One was, uh, the beginning,
uh,
the again,
the pumice common treatment regimen with
a 40 day period beginning with fasting
and then the administration of Mercury,
which had been used in the treatment
of skin disorders over the centuries,
diseases such as scabies.
So mercury was sometimes applied.
It was applied in lots of different ways.
Desperate remedies for
a desperate disease.
Ointments were applied
to the skin lesions.
There was so called general friction in
which applications of mercury were made
to the whole body.
Sometimes it was administered internally,
but as you know,
mercury is extremely toxic.
It causes great salvation of falling out
of the teeth and then serious and often
life threatening symptoms.
But salivation seemed to be the
right approach according to humorless
principles.
It would lead to an evacuation
of the pecant humor.
And it also,
and here was a factor.
It seemed to work when applied
to second stage syphilis,
perhaps simply because as we've already
seen second stage syphilis goes into
spontaneous and often lengthy remission
and it was possible to argue that it was
the therapy,
the treatment that had been effective and
perhaps the suffering that accompanied
this particular treatment provided
some moral satisfaction to those who
administered it.
Another a remedy that
was tried was Guyana,
which is a hard wood from
a tree in the new world.
It was ground into saw dust and made into
a decoction that patients drank twice
a day for 40 days.
We see these 40 days appearing
over and over in quarantine.
The 40 day fasting,
the regimen for mercury,
the regimen for Guyana will.
All of this of course had
a religious background
and so the Guy App was administered for
40 days during which there was fasting
at the same time.
Then so Gaia,
chuck and Mercury Worthy,
so we might say the miracle drugs,
the wonder drugs of their era.
There were other indications
also recommended for syphilis,
bloodletting bounce,
purgation cauterization of the Boyles.
Well an important impact.
Then the next thing I want to point out
is the impact of syphilis on medical
science.
We already in this gives
us a moment of review.
We know already the traditional approach
to these and other diseases that they
were an imbalance of humors.
There was had been no idea of
discreet entities that were diseases,
diseases.
We're an individual matter depending on
the constitution of the patient and the
environmental influences
that acted on him or her
and the 19th century.
However,
we've seen already that diseases fully
crystallized into forms of specific
entities that were actually biological
entities that existed apart from the body
of the individual sufferer will the
period from the 1490s to the 19th century,
the period that embraced both plague and
the great POCs and then modern syphilis
mark and error of transition,
and I would argue that syphilis was
something that propelled this transition
forward.
Remember how traditional medicine as
taught at universities and practice by the
elite physicians was that the truth
about disease was to read the classics.
Hippocrates and Galen supplemented
later in the Middle Ages by astrology.
So for humor list physicians.
Then that was the way it was proceeded
on when fuzzy when syphilis for struck,
there were disputations in which people
sought the truth of the disease by
looking through into the [inaudible]
or what Galen had written.
And so there were disputes,
uh,
disputations that were formerly
held, um, through library.
The challenge of syphilis was that it
was a pandemic that was difficult to
explain within the traditional
framework of humor realism.
At the same time, the disease had
no real place in the classics,
humor,
realism was static and had no way
of accommodating emerging diseases.
So what do you do with the disease
that was unknown to the ancients?
Syphilis was also clearly contagious.
Everyone could see that.
And so there was obviously some more
biphasic substance that passed from one
body to another. The disease, in other
words, seem to be something specific.
And this helped to promote also the
idea of a new concept of disease and
syphilis tried physicians
because it really was an
incurable disease at the time
and until the late 20th century didn't
respond to the classical recommendations
for therapy.
All of this made it a major
challenge to humorless orthodoxy.
And with that, I would
say we've reviewed, um,
this period of syphilis and plague that
presented a major impact on society and
a major impact on medical science.
And we've run out of time this
morning and next time, uh,
having had our review session,
we'll come back to the 19th
century and deal with the debate,
the huge medical debate between,
um,
contagiousness and anti contagiousness.